in the shadow of war ukraine's president
turned to a building signifying peace
keeve's thousand-year-old saint sophia
cathedral the setting for his latest
video message marking orthodox easter
sunday
easter symbolizes the greatest victory
of life over death each of us is asking
god only one thing everyone says the
same words the words of a great and
united prayer
great lord save ukraine
sunday also marks two months since
russian forces invaded ukrainian
authorities urged those celebrating the
christian festival to follow services
online
but some still made their way to church
for easter blessings
this is butcher outside kiev a town
that's seen some of the worst violence
of this conflict
in other parts of the country artillery
fire could be heard as easter services
were held
ukraine had joined the un and pushing
for an easter truce but with no success
in nearby the sun is shining and the sky
is clear but there's no peace in my soul
i very very much want ukraine to have
liberty love and hope
others in the eastern city of zeparia
were too nervous to stay for mass
circles
we didn't enter the church we did
everything quickly we received our
blessings from the priest and we are now
on our way home
the conflict has divided the orthodox
church
the russian patriarch and ally of
president vladimir putin has thrown his
support behind the war and used his
sermons to justify it
that's angered church leaders in ukraine
and others across the orthodox faith its
spiritual leader has pushed for an end
to the fighting calling it an
indescribable human tragedy
russia's annexation of crimea led to a
part of ukraine's clergy splitting from
the moscow-led branch in 2018
there are fears the war could further
rupture the wider church
president vladimir zelinsky urged
ukrainians not to let anger overwhelm
them
today's great holiday gives us the great
hope and belief that light will win over
darkness good will win over evil life
will win over death
therefore ukraine will win inevitably
a prayer for peace and hope heard and
felt across ukraine
alexia o'brien al jazeera